so I pledged to donate fifty percent of
my income for the remainder of 2020
towards organizations that support the
black lives matter movement I will do my
part and I urge a fashion in the street
to do the same Joan I'm looking forward
to talking to you all week because I
feel like what you're doing is so
powerful I want you to talk to us a
little bit about a little bit but talk
to us about donating my wage what is
this how did you come up with the idea I
came up with the idea just out of
frustration you know you know being on
lockdown like everyone else on covin and
seeing how the world was just imploding
with you know so much social injustice
and so many things happening you know as
an individual that is a concerned
citizen it's like what can I do to make
this situation better how can I give
back and at certain points I did feel
helpless so I was just thinking you know
how can I basically integrate what I do
with a movement and the way I thought
about it was you know creating a donate
my wage Organa King all from an idea
that the next post that I was gonna do
related to a brand I was gonna donate
half of my wage to organizations of the
black lives matter movement right right
so what made you say I'm gonna give up
half of my income why have uhm yeah I
don't know because I figured it was
easier amount for people to understand
that I was sacrificing a good amount
towards a good cause and towards
organizations that people are actually
making a difference and they're putting
their time their effort and energy into
changing systemic you know in Justices
within our society so I figured it was
it was easier to kind of understand yeah
no seriously and then when you go on the
website you're able to donate 30 percent
of your income or even just your hourly
income to donate have exactly yeah I'm
just trying to like it's trying to make
a huge impact
so that people can pay attention but
once you go on the website it's pretty
easy you calculate your yearly income
and you can
it's a suggested donation so you can
either give your hourly your daily your
weekly or monthly or there's just a
custom amount that you can give I think
any little helps and it's easy because I
picked the eleven organizations that I
kind of can relate to and some of them
are related towards women empowerment
education towards the justice system so
you basically you can choose where you
want it to go
what is the fashion industry actually
going to do about it is this just
another trend well it's not time to give
us a real seat at the table because we
are worthy because we are talented
because we are unique I want to talk
about your post on Instagram where you
called on the fashion industry to stand
up to racism I was watching it I was
like Joan go go go every point you may
it was so strong you were very
passionate and it definitely came from a
personal place what is it what has the
response been from the industry after
you shared your story and your thoughts
on what's going on you know it was nerve
wrecking and I had a lot of sleepless
nights because I think sometimes people
see the outside perspective of you know
the glitz the glamour and not everything
that shines is gold you know my success
came with a lot of failures it came with
a lot of rejection and that's the part
where I kept to myself and I used that
kind of like a flame from my fire to
keep pushing because it's like okay I
can't give up now you know I came from a
small town in Porto Rico or it's like I
need to show the world that you can make
it regardless of so the support has been
incredible I've been so overwhelmed with
you know friends that I've made in this
industry from people who work at brands
designers hitting me up saying you know
I commend you for your braveness and for
speaking out because a lot of them have
known me throughout my career so they've
seen they've seen my struggles I hear my
cries and they supported me throughout
my career so no I was I was overjoyed
yeah at the same time because in sight
I'm sticking my neck out to my beloved
fashion industry this is your chance the
moment where you speak up and
demonstrate that if you care if you
truly care then show it I know that I
mean of course I feel like that's why I
was so proud of you and I mean all of us
we were so proud of you because it is a
brave thing to do you know you could
easily get blacklisted or people may say
you're difficult to work with so the
fact that you push past those fears and
still did it because that's what you
believe in it just speaks to who you are
I think it's important because you know
in every industry as you may know like
it's hard to break through and then once
you're there you kind of have to like
walk on eggshells because you are a
mercy of someone else so I think I've
earned my right in this industry to
speak my truth and I am a professional I
my resume speaks for itself so at this
point is like you know how can I speak
my truth and encourage others to do the
same and I think that we're stronger in
numbers and you know sometimes you need
a little bit of a push to empower others
to going towards the right direction and
and now it's so important because
everybody is actually listening in
paying attention they have to so in
doing that if I come from a place of you
know my personal experiences you can't
take that away from me I'm not bashing
at you I'm not you know attacking I'm
just saying what I've lived through and
what the industry has
so yeah what are some of the struggles
that you have dealt with if you don't
mind sharing I think at the beginning
there was not many opportunities because
you know as I expressed in my video game
it was a lot of stereotyping right so
there was only one quota to fill which
was a black girl right if I fill that
quota I did see another girl in the room
that looked like me and all the industry
is kind of like here for yourself
but I came from humble beginnings and I
grew up in a household where I saw
different ethnicities different colors
different backgrounds so like I always
wanted my work to reflect that and you
know I I take so much pride seeing other
people that look like myself
in places of you know a position of
power or being able to showcase their
greatness right being the token black
girl what I mean I know from experience
as well but I just want to hear your
thoughts what is the type of
responsibility you feel like it's on
your shoulders or you felt like it's on
your shoulders in the past yeah like
it's a lot of pressure because you know
with me I'm not only the other thing
that people never she's not a man but
Mike is cheap either and it's like not
all of it and I'm proud of it it's just
the way I am and yeah it's like you know
when you walk into the room I'm not
lumping in just as Joel small as I'm
walking in you know there's a community
I mean because everything is gonna be
reflected on that you know if you speak
out your mind who wish the Inc angry
black right you know she she has her own
right all she's giving up that's not it
is just you know all I'm a woman I'm
educated and I feel if I need to speak
up I will do so without disrespecting
anybody and we should take out the color
away from gray as right but you know
growing up you always know that
like my father had told me before I came
into the industry said John the day you
were born you bore me two strikes on
your back he said you're a woman and
you're black and I was like ah you know
you're hearing that from your own father
and he's kind of like breaking it down
to you how world the world actually
works and so you know going into an
industry I kind of knew that and is like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna prove you wrong
I'm gonna fool I can do it so it
definitely was a lot of pressure I
always want to do myself and when you
walk walk with pride they don't want to
see your doing this
that's stupidness because what you're
doing you know taking their eyes off or
buying the product you have on yeah I
would say I love you and your dad's
relationship he is hilarious it's in the
vogue video that you are that it's so
cute I love him you kind of hit on it a
little bit but you are a trailblazer in
this industry you were the first
afro-latino
to be the face of Estee Lauder and even
with that did you ever feel that you had
to dim your blackness or your Spanish
roots to get opportunities in this
industry not dim it's just I think you
because brands didn't understand my
cultural heritage they never knew how to
explore it so they would only market me
as what she saw right or not what I
represent so like I never did that like
I am as boisterous my personality comes
out wherever I go I'm loud if you want
to call it I'm funny so I never did but
I didn't know I had to carry myself a
certain way and when I am in certain
rooms show them that I am i can't speak
that I'm educated that you know I'm
business minded so yeah you you I
thought I'd dim it down I just know how
to code switch or navigate you know not
for sure for sure on in your open letter
we're not in your open letter but in the
caption for your open letter on
Instagram you said we are not a trend
can you expound on that a little bit
I say that because one fashion do follow
trends and sometimes I felt that when it
came to the diversity or the inclusive
includes inclusivity subject a lot of
brands kind of did jump on a bandwagon
and they were always like well you know
I'll use Fenty for example you know when
she came out straight off the bat she
was forty shades or I don't hold me but
she came out with a variation of shades
and that was her core message right and
then other brands were like well we hide
those shades to her and are pushing that
back message in that marketing and it's
like well if you did then you should
have done that you should have waited
and so people were talking and
celebrating this woman for actually
including everyone equally and now
you're just saying that oh yeah we had
it's like well you should have done the
same thing so it's like we are not a
trend we are here to stay you know
regardless of what anyone says the black
community is the remote use for
inspiration and you know like it or not
we do make things though and we have
create relevance in brands I love that
you said that beautifully from your
opinion based off of your opinion right
now what does the fashion industry need
to do to change I know that's probably a
large question but just because sum it
up in a simple way going back to like me
being in a room and me being the only
one I think it's important and it's
essential that their creative teams
should be equally reflective of
diversity so not just the optics of what
you see on Billboard's or images but the
team and the court itself where your
being the most creative should have
people of all backgrounds you know hire
a diverse staff have an internal
cultural team so that you don't have
mishaps with
your your company when you're marketing
something and you like oh sorry we
didn't mean to offend you right
I feel like it has to come from the
inside and also when people in power or
people who are leaders should definitely
mentor others and uplift them at some
time I think you know having this
conversation and making people feel
uncomfortable is going to create growth
now if make everyone involved towards
the right direction so that therefore
they can make it their mission to move
towards the right direction recently
you've teamed up with Ashley Graham
Kendall and Gigi Hadid you all teamed up
with British Vogue to donate your
clothes so the N double AC P and NHS
have you caught on any of them to help
you or to actually sign one to donate my
wage and actually done in a matter of
like two weeks it was like super crazy
because I already knew that I was going
to come out with a message especially
see you know the Instagram post or like
certain brands not post about something
it's going around it or you know not
trying to rock the boat that kind of
like created this fire in me where it's
like well I've given so much of myself
to these brands and the least you can do
is speak up and say I stand with you
guys I see where you're coming from this
is on a human level this is my marketing
strategy it is just can you can you see
us as equals and actually use your
platform and use your voice to support
us and saucer and brands I didn't and I
was like oh my god naked I'm like okay
I'm definitely speaking so I made the
video
and then I came across this website
donate my wage org which was done with
flight view I'm pregnant basically
created it for
music industry ok and when I saw I fell
in love with it I'm like oh my god this
is exactly what I'm thinking about like
the synergy was incredible and they
basically handed it off to me and said
send me off my bus and they're like we
want to make sure that this lives
throughout that it's not just a music
industry so I ready I'm gonna make sure
that it crosses and guessing industry
and yeah the next steps I am gonna have
my friends rock I'm coming I know you
probably hear this all the time but
we're appreciative of you we're so proud
of you and thank you for everything
you're doing before we let you go can
you let us know how we can get involved
with donating my wage and learn more
information about it ok so you can go to
donate my wage org and basically I just
wanted to make it easy for people like
myself to go on on an online platform
where you can donate there's various
organizations
I chose 11 of them and while you're
there at the same time it goes directly
to their website so you can further
educate yourself and you can participate
and learn so check it out
[Music]